hey 42 here in 1798 british forces
fighting against revolutionary france
captured a friendship the hush off the
coast of ireland
and the soldiers and sailors on board
were taken to a prison camp near
liverpool
in those days prisoners of war were
given standard rations paid for by their
own country
so france was footing the bill for these
men normally
that was no bother but it just so
happens there was one man
on board the host ship he would really
mess with the french army's accountants
born in poland charles de mary was a man
with an enormous
and unusual appetite who could
and would eat almost anything
he'd initially enlisted in the prussian
army as a teenager
fighting against a french in the war of
the first coalition
which was basically an attempted land
grab by other european monarchs
whilst the french revolutionaries were
rising up and executing their own king
louis xv but his service there did not
last long
as the prussian army was suffering from
food shortages
and this guy knew where his priorities
lay demary promptly marched into the
town his comrades were besieging
and surrendered to the french general
there
in return for a large melon which
he ate rained and all on the spot
demary then joined the french fighting
against his former prussian employers
and his eating habits soon shocked his
new colleagues
while stationed at an army base near
paris he was so unsatisfied with the
rations he was receiving
that he ate 174 cats
in a single year only killing them first
if he wasn't already too hungry and he
would regularly consume
a kilogram or two of grass a day
if other food wasn't available to mary's
preference
however was for meat and he liked it raw
his favorite dish was raw bull's liver
but he soon showed that trifling things
like morality
wouldn't stop him from trying other
delicacies
whilst on board the soon to be captured
hush
a fellow sailor had his legs shot clean
off by cannon fire
and damari took the chance to chow down
it said the severed limb had to be
pulled from his teeth
and thrown into the sea when the heart
was captured by the british de mary
didn't stay a prisoner of war for long
he soon became an experimental subject
for fascinated british doctors
he was already on 10 rations a day when
physicians tested his appetite
by offering him raw cows order beef by
the bucket load
and even several pounds of tallow
candles
all of which he happily wolfed down
whilst it isn't recorded what became of
de mary after the experiments
ran their course doctors today remained
fascinated by his story
what caused his unusual appetite it's
been suggested that some form of
malnourishment local to the region where
he lived and served
caused the mary's insatiable hunger
a theory that may be given weight by the
tale of a frenchman
called terrari because curiously enough
damari was not the only incredible eater
present in the war of the first
coalition
and if you thought charles de mary was
weird then loosen that belt a notch
because
we're just getting started you'll also
want to loosen your belt
to consume all the world's most valuable
business ideas
from today's sponsor trends if you're a
budding entrepreneur
investor or just have ambitions for
personal growth
trends is an absolute gold mine let me
tell you
in business timing and insider knowledge
are everything when you subscribe to
trends you get access to a community of
industry leaders in virtually every
field
where you can learn how to capitalize on
emerging opportunities
learn growth strategies seo and much
more trends also provides regular
signals
that tell you exactly what those
emerging markets
are and it's the only place i've found
to get that
information it's like having a time
machine that makes you money
the business experts and industry
leaders at trends also publish regular
articles
to teach you how to be better at
business and succeed
no matter what your product is i
particularly enjoyed the trends article
54 profit a look inside the lucrative
storage unit business i'm amazed at the
wealth of information in this deep dive
into the surprisingly lucrative storage
industry
did you know the storage unit industry
has an extremely low failure rate
under 10 right now you can get your
first
two weeks for just one dollar go to
trends.co
42 for your one dollar two-week trial
don't miss this one guys the man known
as terraree was born to poor parents
around 1772 in the french countryside
near lyon
and lived during the french revolution
which was pretty unfortunate for him
france's population exploded in the 18th
century increasing by almost 50 percent
which combined with years of poor
harvests created severe food shortages
these were prime conditions for a
political uprising
and definitely not the time for a rural
peasant family
to have a son that was an eating machine
not that you'd know it to look at him
terrari
was at first glance fairly unremarkable
he was of average height and weight and
standard issue fair hair
but that was where his normality ended
look
closer and you'd notice the unusually
thin
lips the wide mouth filled with stained
teeth and a pair of permanently
bloodshot
eyes at the age of 17 tarare was capable
of eating a quarter of a cow about 50
kilograms of meat
close to his own body weight in a single
day
it's no surprise his parents quickly
kicked him out of the family home
unable to provide for his extraordinary
needs
a lonely hungry teenager tararee was
initially reduced to
begging and stealing to get by until
he found the company of a rather
unsavory band of travellers
but as we'll see unsavory wasn't a
problem for terrari
his newfound bodies turned out to be a
group of thieves and prostitutes
who posed as street performers to rob
their audience
whilst one of them would entertain the
crowd the rest would slip through it
nimble fingers sliding coins from
pockets
in terraria they'd found a gem of an act
someone who would captivate huge crowds
with ease
as for terrari the show itself was his
reward
since he'd challenge onlookers to give
him anything to eat
and no matter how unbelievable or
inedible the item
he'd consume it some of the feats made
use of the quirks of his anatomy
whether natural or a result of his
constant eating
he could fit a dozen eggs in his cheeks
like some sort of giant hamster
he could also toss whole apples straight
down his throat
and would do so by the basket load then
came the stranger items corks
rocks bits of metal all gobbled up with
ease
but his favorite delicacies as well as
the ones that really drew a crowd
were live animals particularly snakes
they went down the same way as
everything else thrown into tarara's
belly
without a second fort as terrari
performed
and by performed i mean stuffed his face
with things he shouldn't have
to the delight and disgust after
watching crowd
his stomach would expand swelling up
like a balloon
and giving him the appearance of a
heavily pregnant woman
such fluctuations in size on a regular
basis
took their toll on tararva's body the
skin of his stomach
was so loose he could as another parlor
trick
as if he needed any more tie it around
his own waist
like a belt made of his own skin
how they haven't made a horror movie
about this guy yet
i have no idea because being in close
proximity to terrari
was a pretty horrific experience
his sagging skin was hot to the touch
and he sweated constantly
his unique body odor caused by all the
raw meat
and god knows what else he ate was so
fouled
it was said to manifest itself as a
visible
vapour which rose from his skin that's
right
terrari gave off real life cartoon style
stink lines most people couldn't stand
to be within 20 paces of him
which by the standards of 18th century
french peasants
is some going he also suffered somewhat
predictably
from bouts of flatulence and this may be
where his name comes from
you see there's some debate over whether
terrari was his real name or a nickname
and those that argued the latter point
to bomb bomb terrari
a popular french phrase at the time to
describe
loud powerful explosions much like the
man's intestinal orchestra
as well as his own unique scent
terrare's behavior was unusual too
affected either by his diet or the
underlying condition which caused his
appetite
he was constantly tired and distracted
showing many of the classic warning
signs of being extremely malnourished
despite the fact he was constantly
chowing down
on almost every edible thing inside and
plenty that wasn't edible
his notoriety grew and just as robbie
williams would centuries later
terraria decided he was too popular for
the other chumps in his troop
it was time to strike out as a solo act
he left leon behind
and headed to paris to perform at such
prestigious venues
as pon nuth the bridge that was the
bustling center of the city
for crime and commerce alike at the time
his shows were just as popular in the
capital as they had been before
as much as success can be defined by
crowds continuing to gather
and giving him inedible objects to
swallow
but there was one notable hiccup one day
during his regular act terrare suffered
a severe intestinal blockage
and became quite unwell even by his own
foul standards
it's not known what object finally
proved too much for his poor tortured
insides
but the assembled crowd carried terrari
to ottel due
a hospital near notre dame here he was
provided with the strongest laxatives
french medicine had to offer
and well they did their job
and it's best we leave it at that some
of you are probably eating right now
once cured terrare was quickly back to
his confident self
boldly offering to swallow the doctor's
pocket watch
as proof of his recovery the doctor
agreed on one condition that he was then
allowed to cut terrare open
to retrieve the watch so much for the
hippocratic oaf
terraria wisely refused after
this close call not
[Music]
pressed into available service whilst
we're not sure why he joined the army or
how
willing a decision it was it seems
unlikely that meagan military food
supplies were part of his thought
process
due to his voracious appetite he was
provided with quadruple rations
and he'd trade favors with other
soldiers in return for more food
but even that wasn't enough and such was
his hunger
terrare was soon reduced to scrounging
through rubbish heaps for scraps
now this may all sound a little
far-fetched but one
it's gonna get a lot wilder and two
tarare's condition is surprisingly well
documented
that's because he was sent to an army
hospital in eastern france
near the german border suffering from
exhaustion
there his insatiable cravings which saw
him eat
hospital bandages gained him the
attention of a well-known
and highly respected doctor baron pierre
francois percy
is one of the pioneers of military
surgery he was chief surgeon to the
french army as well as a university
professor
the inventor of several battlefield
medical implements
and should probably be considered an
all-around trustworthy guy
alongside the other military doctors at
the hospital baron percy performed
several experiments on terrari which he
detailed in notes and reports featured
in reputable medical texts
such as the study of medicine popular
physiology
and the london medical and physical
journal
it is from these published medical works
that the majority of the information
we know about terraria originates whilst
psychological testing found he was
apathetic but
otherwise pretty sane the physical test
terraria was put through
delivered remarkable results the doctors
first set out an enormous spread
a meal meant for 15 labourers terrari
ate and drank everything which included
gargantuan meat pies
and four gallons of milk before falling
into an almighty food coma
and eventually waking up hungry again
clearly volume wasn't a problem for this
eating machine
so what about the animals that
supposedly made up terraria's street
show
dubious of his claims the doctors gave
him a live eel
and watched as he crushed its head
between his teeth
then swallowed it whole dozens of spiny
ribs and all
bear in mind this was nearly a hundred
years before the heimlich maneuver
became common practice
yet somehow terrari never choked to
death on any of the bones
or other assorted odds and ends he
consumed
now eels up inside you is one thing
but pet lovers may want to mute this
part
because it's only going to get worse
from here next on the menu
was a cat which according to percy's
notes
terrare tore in half and eviscerated
before eating everything
but the bones then displaying abilities
that oddly mirrored his meals
he coughed up the fur for some reason
these experiments continued
you'd have thought once they'd seen he
could eat animals
that would be that but no next came
lizards
snakes ferrari's favorite flesh
apparently
and even puppies all were consumed with
apparent relish at some point in all of
this
the french army politely inquired as to
whether terraria would be rejoining his
comrades in military duty
but percy and his colleagues were a
canny bunch
and where most people would have simply
been disgusted the doctors
had spotted an opportunity their last
experiment was to see if terraria could
swallow
and then pass documents if they were
secured within a small container
they had him swallow a box with a note
inside which
shall we say re-emerged the following
day
intact and legible ferrari
repeated this trick at french army
headquarters
possibly even in the presence of
napoleon himself
and suddenly this noxious insatiable man
transformed from a burden into an
asset it was friends general alexandre
de buane
who decided to use terrari as a covert
messenger
the plan was to send him across the
german border into prussia
to deliver a message safely and sconced
in his gut
to an imprisoned french colonel
terraria's payment for the mission
was a wheelbarrow full of 30 pounds of
bull organs
which he received in advance and ate
immediately in front of the assembled
military commanders
i prefer paypal but each to their own
was this the start of a new chapter in
terraria's life
as a brilliant spy sadly not
disguised as a prussian peasant he was
unsurprisingly captured a short distance
into germany
why unsurprisingly well no doubt they
could smell him a mile away
and he was presumably eating everything
in sight
but what really gave the game away was
that terrari didn't speak a word of
german
it's safe to say he wasn't exactly james
bond
the prussian forces that had captured
him led by general zergley
tortured him for information to
terrare's credit
he lasted a full day before he gave up
his mission telling them
about the box in his stomach but since
he had no idea what the message
actually said what was there to do but
to chain him to a toilet
and wait sadly
both the prussians and terrari were in
for a surprise
the note after all that was of little
importance some accounts claimed it
simply asked the recipient
to let de bohanes know if the message
had been received
clearly this had merely been a test run
to see if terraria could really be of
use
the prussians weren't too pleased by
this development i'm guessing the guy
that fished the box out of terrare's
still warm excrement was especially
miffed
general zergley had terraria whipped
beaten
and marched to the gallows to be
executed but at the last moment
as the noose was tightened around
terraria's neck zergly
called the execution off whether it was
a nasty trick planned from the start or
a genuine
just in time change of heart we'll never
know
but eventually terrari was released back
to france
with little more than a slap on the
wrist finally
fed up excused upon of being defined by
his eating abilities
tararee returned to the military
hospital and begged to be cured of his
condition
to his credit baron percy tried a host
of different remedies
from wine vinegar to tobacco pills
to lordanim a solution of opium and
alcohol
terrari was even put on a diet
consisting exclusively of soft-boiled
eggs
which must have been a full-time job for
one poor chicken
but nothing helped whilst attempts to
cure him were ongoing
his endless hunger remained he would
regularly sneak out of the hospital to
fight
dogs and other wild animals for the
scraps left outside the butcher's shop
he even turns to rather sinister
vampiric habits
by drinking the blood of patients
undergoing bloodletting
and on more than one occasion he was
caught trying to eat corpses in the
hospital morgue
all this time baron percy stood by
terrari
resisting calls for him to be sent to an
asylum
steadfastly claiming his patient's
ailment was entirely physical
rather than mental and that the right
treatment could cure him
but then something happened that even
percy couldn't
explain away in 1794
a 14 month old toddler disappeared from
the hospital
there were no witnesses nor was there
any evidence
but the finger of blame was quickly and
perhaps
understandably pointed at the one
patient
already known to eat live animals and
dead people
after all was that next step really so
much of a moral leap
though he denied it terrari was chased
from the hospital by an angry mob
the tale of terrare then goes cold for
no less than four years
he left the army and disappeared as far
as we know
but suddenly out of the blue baron percy
received a message from a hospital in
versailles
his old patient had turned up with not
long to live
and had requested the doctor's presence
enthralled as he was by this medical
marvel
percy rushed to the hospital there
terraria told him
he believed he was dying from a golden
fork he'd swallowed two years previously
a good theory but percy was confident
the advanced tuberculosis terraria was
suffering from
might have had something to do with it
with percy by his side
terraria passed away his death filled a
room with noxious fumes
leaving the doctor struggling to breathe
once it was
safe to re-enter they began their
autopsy
realizing they did not have lung to
complete it
soon after death terrare's body began to
rapidly decompose
still bravely pinching their noses the
doctors cut him
open hoping to understand what had
caused his unique affliction
terraria's intestines were rotten and
dripping with puss
his liver was a swollen decaying mush
and his stomach was a massive ulcers
that filled almost his entire abdominal
cavity
oh sorry if you're eating you should
have probably paused that bit
my bad they prised open his gigantic jaw
which dreads so wide a cylinder four
inches in diameter fit
cleanly inside there they noted
it was possible to see straight down
terrare's wide throat
which opens directly into his gut he was
basically one giant intestine
all the way down sadly this was as far
as the autopsy went
as the smell drove even percy from the
room
and terrare's corpse was disposed of
before it became even more toxic
so what caused terraria's condition
it may have been malnourishment that
drove both him and charles de mary to
eat unfathomable quantities of
unbelievable foodstuffs
other theories include a brain injury or
tumor that led to either a defective
hypothalamus the region of the brain
that controls the thyroid gland
or damaged amygdalae the clusters of
nuclei that control emotional responses
malfunction from either of these may
have caused hypothyroidism
where the thyroid that regulates
multiple bodily functions
including metabolism goes absolutely
ballistic
symptoms of hyperthyroidism include the
fine
thinning hair that terrare sported as
well as
an excessive appetite rapid weight loss
and sweating
in essence it's the perfect recipe for
creating a wreaking devourer
of gargantuan proportions modern-day
analysis of terraria's case
also concludes he may have been host to
an intestinal parasite
like a hookworm if such a parasite was
present
in terraria's stomach it's conceivable
that he could have eaten
large amounts without gaining weight
doctors haven't seen
cases of polyphagia excessive appetite
as severe as evil man's in the years
since
though these days it's likely the
underlying conditions would have been
treated far
sooner we may never know exactly what
caused the mary and terrari to eat
everything in sight
but we can say the world will likely
never see a case like theirs again
and for that owners of all you can eat
buffets around the world
can breathe a huge sigh of relief thanks
for watching
thanks again to trends for sponsoring
today's video
don't forget to check them out using the
link in the description below